sep tember 1965 Helen Hadley hall I'm
beginning graduate studies in French and
I have a recurring dream Jean Bosch
director of graduate studies in French
calls me into his office and announces
in his genial way med was L we've
discovered that you were admitted to the
program by mistake we really intended to
admit someone else goodbye why should I
have such a nightmare well maybe in part
because it was the first time I'd ever
lived away from home as a college
student I lived with my family in
bensonhurst brooklyn and I commuted to
st. Joseph's to subway trains a bus and
a walk it was also the first time I'd
been in any school not run by the
sisters of st. Joseph and the first time
since eighth grade I'd been in a school
with boys a lot of us i'm sure we're
anxious but i think i may have had more
reason than most i was the child of a
father who did not finish high school
and of a mother who had a commercial
course that is to say she learned typing
and shorthand my three older siblings
all had either commercial or vocational
courses in high school and none of them
went beyond high school and in our 1965
yale entering cohort of about 40
students into the french program i was
one of just two who had never been to
France despite the nightmare and the
uncertainty it all worked out and the
five years I spent in New Haven the last
of them by the way in Timothy Dwight
College the year the college went co-ed
we're among the happiest of my life and
they were certainly the most formative
God knows I studied hard in fact I
reconnected last month with one of my
graduate school friends I hadn't seen
her but twice in the intervening 40
years and both times only briefly she
told me a story in her first year at
Yale she wasn't doing well academically
and she'd become despondent she claims
that I said this to her Ellen you have
to work harder you don't have to work as
hard as I do but you have to work harder
I was appalled I mean what evidence on
my part she however maintains that my
belief in her helped her to succeed
which i can add she did quite
brilliantly I don't remember playing
this role for her but I do remember
other students playing a similar role
for me the graduate student culture was
collaborative in my second year at Yale
as I was casting about for a paper topic
I asked a third-year student if he had
any ideas he was rushing off on a trip
but to my stupefaction two days later I
got a postcard this was in the time long
before email of course I got a postcard
listing five possible paper topics all
of them excellent I've saved that
postcard and I remain a friend of the
person who sent it to me who now works
by the way for a major foundation doing
good for countless aspiring young
professionals such as I was then i also
have a distinct memory of preparing for
PhD orals three of us worked together we
divided up the rather long list into
three parts and we each took primary
responsibility for one third reading all
the materials making notes and then
conferring that sort of group effort is
common today certainly it is at Hamilton
College we're on president but it was
not so common in the 1960s Bob Dawson
one of the three remained a friend until
his death in Paris a few years ago he
became a distinguished bibliophile after
he finished his Yale degree and over the
years the loan of rare books from his
private collection enabled almost all of
my own work the second of the three left
the profession to become a lawyer I
hadn't seen her in 20 years when last
year out of the blue as I was finishing
up a manuscript on women and aging in
18th century France I called her up and
asked her if she'd read it she said yes
she read it and she made wonderful
suggestions and proposed my very best
chapter title why am I telling you this
what I mean to say is that my fellow
Yale students smart quirky and generous
and able
my own success had the atmosphere had
been cut throat I would have shriveled
up and they've continued to play an
important role in my life in fact I
married one of them who became the most
constant and faithful of my supporters
then of course there were the teachers
zhang jie shalt know I'll be back Victor
Bombay Jean Bosch those men all of them
yes men taught me how to read and how to
think and especially George may my
dissertation director and incidentally
or perhaps not so incidentally the
dissertation director of my husband in
George mais seminar I made acquaintance
with an 18th century Dutch writer named
Isabel de shou yeah she is still not
exactly a household name except perhaps
in my own household I admire her
exemplary tolerance her largesse her
interest in educating youth and I admire
to the way she wrote her insistence on
simplicity and directness over
pretension or bombastic overstatement in
these attributes she resembles the
teachers I so loved at Yale when I
emulate those traits I'm most successful
in my current work educating the
students of Hamilton College many of
them first generation like me in
academia as in the world at large we
meet a rich diversity of people geniuses
prima donnas Saints mono maniacs none of
them has come as a surprise to me for I
learned to understand such characters
when I first encountered them in new
haven in the pages of malaya whoso vote
a about Zach post and Colette I will by
the way never stop believing that the
best preparation for any way of life is
the study of literature or one of the
other disciplines that a liberal
education offers my graduate my
gratitude rather to the Yale graduate
school is absolutely immense it took a
chance on a poor provincial naive girl
from Brooklyn it gave me a fellowship
and the best of education it gave me the
example of brilliant devoted teachers
who
spired me then and whose memory inspires
me still and have provided me with
friends who have never stopped
supporting me Thank You Yale